frère avait une amoureuse qui était
mannequin à ce moment là et c'est elle
qui me conseillait qui m'avait donné
conseille d'aller dans une agence donc
j'arrive dans cette agence avec c'est
vrai c'est tout autre carte orange et y
compris c'est un métier qui avait assez
peu d'intérêt parce que la partie
créative de ce métier là est assez
minime puisque c'est un métier dans
lesquelles la partie créative sont le
photographe
le styliste le dessinateur le maquilleur
le coiffeur fait la mannequin et comme
un peu l'objet de cette création ou la
cerise sur le gâteau donc on pensait
jamais que personne ne s'intéresserait à
nous qu'on était vaguement
interchangeables et notre génération a
bénéficié d'une espèce d'intérêt tout à
fait inexplicable en ce qui concerne
tout à fait inexplicable mais cet
intérêt voilà ils nous ont mis la
lumière s'est posé sur nous on a
commencé à être interviewé à faire des
interviews de magazines sur les cas
limités que des personnes qui faisait
d'autres métiers ou des pdg ou de ce
champ politique et donc tout d'un coup
on est devenu en quelque sorte un peu
d'aidé star
je crois qu'on a bénéficié d'un intérêt
à une une curiosité tout à fait
inattendue qui débattent
particulièrement relié à notre propre
valeur mais qui était relié voilà au
hasard souvent de choses sont le fruit
du hasard mais l'indépendance c'est une
obsession voyez assez forte que j'ai les
que j'essaie de transmettre à ma fille
qui est très romantique donc je lui dis
souvent
c'est merveilleux le monde c'est la
chose le procès le plus importante pour
nous les filles il ya dépendance qui est
majeure parce que sinon on est pieds et
poings liés à nos parents enjoy c'est
absurde
donc je crois que l'indépendance était
la grande affaire de ma vie et ça l'est
toujours
c'est pas tellement une valeur comme ont
transmis ma mère et ma grand-mère qui
justement été très dépendantes mais si
j'ai peut-être ans en observant
justement en général les condition
féminine que ça m'a donné envie de 2,2
moi-même rompre ce cycle et de parts de
faire autre chose que seulement enfin
seulement c'est à vous de faire autre
chose que dépendre de quelqu'un de faire
autre chose que une vie de femme c'est
vie professionnelle ma rencontre avec
nelson mandela s'était donnant parce que
le matin même du soin ou gelée rencontré
le matin mène j'étais avec mon homme
on était dans la cellule qu'ils avaient
emprisonnés nelson mandela pendant 27
ans et j'étais très étonnée par la
taille de cette cellule qui était une
minuscule cellule très étonné par la la
côte est de l'île sur laquelle avait été
emprisonné mandela est là quand je suis
arrivé j'ai été très étonné par sa
taille et là j'ai compris que si la
cellule m'avait semblé petit à moi en
fait pour lui c'était comme un trou
parce que nous sommes monde et là
c'était un géant à seulement son âme
aussi son corps était encore deux géants
mesurant 1 mètre 90 il avait des grandes
jambes des grands pieds c'était un grand
type et il avait dû même pas s'allonger
pouvoir s'allonger pour dormir au fond
pendant 27 ans et il est sorti le coeur
battant et le corps ouvert toujours donc
oui effectivement ce genre de rencontre
vous remets bien dans laxe j'ai une
photo de trois photos de cette rencontre
que j'ai mis sur le mur ou de la drogue
je travaille chez moi donc puisqu'il
pensait jeu je regarde ça souvenir pour
moi qui ai un sol béni j'avais pas
tellement conscience de ce qu'ils
étaient les brigades rouges et tout ça
mais j'avais je sentais le climat et le
climat était était délétère est arrivé à
paris quand on connaît pas paris et
qu'on a six ans c'est c'est absolument
incroyable
paris c'est une ville qui qui vous
sautent aux yeux quoi etc et qui nous
emporte pour toujours je sais patience
moi j'ai pourtant dieu sait que j'adore
en italie il ya des villes merveilleuse
mais paris paris c'est comme c'est comme
une très très très très belle femme que
le monde entier à venir et qui vieillit
et vous vous êtes senti chez vous tout
de suite non chez moi non pas y aller
pas très hospitalière